did you send her
naked pictures of me
yes
but that's the only time i ever did i
don't and that's supposed to make it
okay
they sent the pictures as revenge
gino admits to sending topless photos of
jasmine to his ex
and for the first time this entire
season i can see why she's furious
i hate you because you broke my heart
y'all it gets so bad she takes gino's
hat off
knowing he doesn't want people to see
his head so take off
them
the petty side of me is thinking ron
jasmine run
plus will you marry me we'll get into
the moment that had me teary-eyed during
mike's proposal to ximena
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia i hope
you are well
if you haven't seen it already i
recently spoke to jasmine
yes that's her she has a new hairstyle
and i must say she sounds like a changed
woman i look at myself
and i'm like
wow i i i'm in shock about my own
actions
jasmine says she regrets her jealous
behavior toward geno in the past
and she also opens up about this new
picture situation we're going to discuss
now
it's like a violation to
to your privacy and especially coming
from someone you you you love before we
get into more of what she had to say
let me lay out exactly what happened for
you
starting from the top i just ignore it
and i just
texted her back like
i don't think we have anything to chat
about gina and jasmine are enjoying
their time on this private island in
panama when she reveals she received a
message on social media from an
ex-girlfriend of geno's not his ex-wife
she says she ignored the message because
they are in a good place
but then geno starts to look nervous
his face
changed
something's going on
his reaction leads jasmine to actually
look into what his ex had to say
that some [ __ ] is about to go down and
what comes next is disturbing
did you send her
naked pictures of me
[Music]
what y'all he tries to lie
no i'm sorry i did not do that liar
so explain this to me because this is
just a screenshot and i have never sent
these notes to anyone but just to you
look
just be honest please no
no that this was like
yes
but that's the only time i ever did i
don't care if it was only once
your son hair
no i was showing her you know
look how hot my girlfriend is so it was
more important for him to prove how hot
his girlfriend is than to protect his
girlfriend
his ex could easily right now post that
picture online
and let's be real
i was on jasmine's instagram the other
day she has a ton of photos in bikinis
a ton
if you want to show how hot she is why
not send one of those i trusted on you
to send you those pictures you know
i will never be able to trust on you
ever
yeah that's painful
and apparently gina reached out to his
ex a few days ago while they were on the
island
[Music]
it's not good
i wish i could take it back but um but
it is true that i sent topless photos to
my ex of jasmine
they sent the pictures as revenge to
show how amazing and wonderful of a
girlfriend i have it at this moment
so you show her boobs
at least now jasmine knows what he
values about her this is a nightmare
while gino tries to look for jasmine
she's getting more information from this
mystery woman
gino's ex is sending me screenshots not
just all my
not pictures but also of the
conversation that she has had with gino
and he was making fun of me calling me
crazy
[Music]
and how explosive i am when i'm jealous
while i was next to him taking a nap
gino is bold
i guess he really didn't learn much from
this you're always defending that you're
temptation and you're comparing me to
herod
but don't worry jasmine's about to
remind him who she is with another one
of her
[Applause]
i'm done with this guy i will never
forgive him
but i want to come from him
and cause as much pain as he has caused
to me
[Music]
um i'm always sorry sorry about that get
up your mouth
you say nuts to your eggs of me why were
you sharing something so personal
speak
that is definitely not something i
should have done but i put it in her
face how hot my new girlfriend is he
needs to stop saying that
jasmine goes on to bring up how he
texted his ex while she was taking a nap
and i was here napping and you two were
texting and she starts to pack her bags
so she can go move into a new room that
i'm guessing she's going to make gino
pay for
you are depressed and you're sick
oh yeah she also threw out the electric
toothbrush she bought her for christmas
well you just throw out the door
garbage
before jasmine leaves the room with her
bags she brings up some shocking but to
be honest not so shocking news
has nothing but just your money
to spend on sugar babies
yep gino used to be part of the sugar
daddy gang
[Music]
not only that he betrayed my trust by
texting my naked pictures to his
ex-girlfriend
[Music]
but his messages with his ex revealed a
part of gino that i just
find disgusting
there were also some other screen grabs
that she sent me from a few years ago
georgina was talking about paying for
sugar babies
after jasmine confronts him about that
he tries to lie again
not true but then she pulls out the
receipts and geno admits that before her
he would pay women only to have dinner
with him
and he still has to pay for the meal
that's a lot
the couple of dinner dates that i went
on
i kind of realized that this wasn't a
very good way for me to find true love
and if i'm on a date
sugar diet if that's gonna be my
business which i'm not interested in
look at me
and i'm intelligent
i will get a sugar daddy that is the
sugar daddy of the sugar daddy not a
crazy old man lawn and depressing from
michigan give me a break ouch
oh jasmine says she wants to hurt him as
bad as he hurt her so she continues to
cut deep with her words
thank god i took that birth control can
you imagine me being pregnant of a sick
person as you are
okay
well if you can't talk peacefully then
you can
jasmine eventually walks out the door
but here's what she told me reflecting
on the situation months later i can just
tell you that
[Music]
it was
it was super sad for me more than being
mad uh
it's something
disappointing for me
it's a it's it's like a violation to
to your privacy and especially coming
from someone you you you love
yeah
okay i know y'all are probably thinking
get to the head get to the head that's
what she says
that was so inappropriate
but here's the tease for the next
episode the moment jasmine knocks geno's
hat off
and reveals what he's been hiding for
this long
voila i'm not the kind of girl who goes
away with it
you did bad to me you'll pay for it you
trash
stop it old man
sign nuts to your ex of me that i trust
on you your breasts are showing that's
correct but they're not nudes
so take off
them
took that man's hat and ran straight for
the door
that was wild but since geno has made
such a big deal out of his head
let's take a look at it
it's not that bad
i'm not sure what's going on in the back
but i guess we'll get a better view next
week
oh jasmine
all right before we go let me show you
this sweet moment
will you marry me
mike proposes to ximena during his last
night in colombia and she says yes
[Music]
but it's a reaction from her son who has
never had a father present in his life
that has me hoping
that these grown-ups don't break his
heart um
gaining harold and juan her children so
i'm
getting like an instant family
it's a really great feeling
[Music]
[Music]
this is no joke when you have kids in
the middle of this
in next episode after mike returns to
america it seems as if things between
him and ximena take an unexpected turn
something seems a little off with ximena
she's just getting a little bit more
distant
he's still sending her money she wants
to get some augmentation for her breasts
she's asked me to pay for it
i think that should stop
ximena hasn't been acting like herself
lately so that's why i need to go back
to colombia
amen i'm here
oh they are stressing me out all right
90 day fans fam there will not be a
before the 90 days episode next week
because of the super bowl but the show
returns the following week and i will be
here with everything you need to know
alright i'll see you next time
[Music]